crow thank you for coming on e to Canada
pride well thank you for having me here
I'm super excited to have you here and I
know you're coming off any award win
last night so congratulations on that
fresh-faced model of the year how does
that feel to win that award last night
it's incredible
I only started over in October so it's
just been a crazy journey so far working
with some amazing brands some amazing
people and to have all that comes to
being an award for being the best fresh
face in Canada right now is just it's
just incredible super exciting and there
was a lot of people from the fashion
industry obviously there last night did
you have a chance to speak to anyone
that maybe you were wanting to meet
there were so many incredible people
that I was just like blown away but Coco
Rocha I was able to meet four briefly
and I've known about her for years so it
was really cool to actually get a chance
to meet her even if it was short Crow's
transformation it is so exciting as soon
as I saw the trailer come out I
immediately emailed out TV and was like
why can I have crowd come off I was
probably 15 at the time that I decided
that I was a guy I knew I couldn't
pretend to be a girl for that much
longer it had gotten to a point where I
was like I need to be a boy tell me
about the idea behind doing the
documentary so originally it was
actually gonna be a photo shoot and me
and my mom went to Gina Hall and she has
a company that has the makeup artists
photographers things like that and she
was like you know what instead of doing
a photo shoot how about we just do a
documentary about the process of doing
the transformation and the transition so
we were like alright yeah let's do it
and so that's how it kind of came to be
so one of the first documentaries of
going through a transition and the
process of hormone surgeries the mental
effects the social effects everything
like that and yeah
going through it yourself and with your
family and friends but having cameras
around you while going through the
transition how difficult was it at times
were the times where you were like you
know just get out or were you totally an
open book just saying shoot everything
occasionally it was hard but typically
it wasn't and then there were some times
where I had a camera myself so even if I
was having a bad day I would kind of
film that and talk about like having a
rough day and you know kind of help me
get through that and get stuff off my
chest just talking about it what do you
hope comes from Crow's transformation I
mean education in the LGBTQ community
and outside of it is so important are
you hoping to just show people what a
trans person has to go through yeah the
real goal with the shooting the
documentary was to have it when it's
completed to be put into schools so that
when people are talking about the sex ed
in elementary school in high school that
it can be a topic that's openly
discussed so kids who are maybe feeling
like oh I feel different but no one else
does so I must be weird I must be
feeling like [ __ ] like no one else ever
will and they can realize that there are
other people out there like them and
they can kind of see that and relate to
that and they can see is this a process
I want to go through or is some things a
little too scary I'm not ready for this
so it kind of will help educate them on
how to do the process but also educate
their friends on how to treat them and
that it's totally normal and it's
totally acceptable and they can go back
to their parents and kind of talk about
that I think that it's finding yourself
is definitely a hard path to do and it
doesn't matter whether you it's to do
with your gender or how you fit in
everyone goes through it in some way or
another so really just finding about who
you are yourself and having the friends
that support you through everything
that's really the most important your
family and friends we see your mom in
the documentary how you know a lot of
LGBTQ people don't have support from the
facts remember how scary it is for them
to come forward and to come to you and
just say this is what's happening with
me I need you and that's what coming out
is is
they need you so having your mother's
support what does that meant to you
it's incredible to have her support even
at first she was a bit hesitant because
the trans people that she knew when
growing up they had decided later on in
life that they had made the wrong choice
and it ended in tragedy for one of them
and then the other one was just really
unhappy for the rest of life so she
didn't want me to go through that same
experience so she was very worried about
my health but once it was as we spent
some time talking about it and she
realized this is who I am and this is
what it is to make me happy then she was
so supportive and just all full of love
and how does it feel now to be yourself
and feel like your true authentic self
out in the world in the modeling world
it's completely different to be able to
be presented as myself and be just I
don't even know how to describe it it's
just amazing to not have to hide myself
and have to pretend to be something I'm
not
so yeah it's really incredible the
biggest change that I notice from the
last time we work together is how happy
you look you are radiating happiness and
confidence
what is modeling do for you personally
like what do you get out of modeling for
me modeling is incredibly fun just to
work with all these creative people and
kind of see the world from their
perspective so yeah it's just really
incredible to get all these different
world views coming from other people and
kind of just relating to them the names
of brands that you wanna pour is like
incredible louis vuitton Balmain um tell
me about having those brands reached out
to you and want you to be part of their
shows or campaigns it's been absolutely
amazing Louie Vuitton was actually my
first job and they were specifically
looking for trans and genderqueer models
so the fact that they were reaching out
into the community across the world to
look for that and kind of have those
people represent their brands to show
that gender no longer is a this and that
in separate box categories that it's
it's more of a free-form and that if you
like something you can wear a regardless
of who or what
you are so I think that's really
incredible that these brands are kind of
coming together and wanting that to
represent them is there a brand that you
were just dying to model for for me it
was Alexander McQueen just because I
I've always loved that kind of Gothic
and kind of punk look so I was able to
walk through the women show and that was
just incredible
so fingers crossed I walked for their
men's show maybe they can put me in a
cool suit
[Music]